bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport comme tous les lundis c'est parti
pour un nouveau tour de l'actu pop du
département en 26 minutes passent au
titre en images il s'appelle frédéric
envie et membre de l'équipe de france de
baseball formé aux cougars de montigny
ce prodige du baseball français partant
telle aventure au japon nous avons suivi
les roues des équipages participant à la
nocturne ce rallye réservé aux voitures
anciennes organisé à versailles ce
week-end et en fin d'émission nathalie
renard est instructeur de krav maga lui
en cours et surtout elle est la première
femme diplômée de france dans sa
fédération portrait à suivre dans cette
édition évidemment en fin d'émission
tous les résultats du week end mais tout
d'abord on passe au rugby et à la
fédérale 3 avec l'entraîneur du plaisir
rugby club philippe berre
première question j'ai l'impression que
vous mener un train d'enfer depuis
quelques journées de corte
bon rythme le projet de jeu depuis trois
ans sur lequel on travaille et commence
à être bien assimilé par tous les
joueurs on a eu à l'intersaison quelques
recrues intéressantes et puis la
dynamique des victoires faisant aussi
bien en première qu'en réserve les
joueurs arrivent sur le terrain avec de
l'assurance et du coup il tente beaucoup
de choses et bien pour l'instant sa
riche en russie et ça fait plaisir parce
qu'il ya des scores intéressants donc du
spectacle oui pour en citer injuste
quelques-uns le 19 janvier dernier vous
gagnez 30 à 3 face à meaux le 12 janvier
36 à 3 face à vincennes et 41 10 le 15
décembre dernier face à sucy cd score
qui permet de conforter votre deuxième
place au classement général d'ailleurs
si vous voulez bien on va jeter un petit
coup d'oeil sur ce classement de la
poule 2 de fédérale 3 vous êtes donc 2e
avec 52 points à 8 points du leader
orléans mais qui est peut-être un petit
peu sur une autre planète 60 points et
surtout le plus important huit points
d'avancé sur le troisième pour tokyo
pour l'instant c'est le scénario presque
idéal j'ai envie de dire pour vous c'est
ce qu'on recherchait un début de saison
l'objectif c'était il ya dans les deux
premiers on l'avait annoncé depuis trois
saisons se qualifier sur les places de
3e 4e qui oblige à des matchs de très
haut niveau dès le premier tour des
phases finales cette année antique si on
pouvait accrocher une deuxième place on
aurait peut-être un 32e plus facile et
jouer un match de montée même si ça doit
pas obligatoirement réussir c'est quand
même un beau challenge et
un bel exploit à atteindre pour les
joueurs cette saison quoi oui la saison
dernière pour le rappeler aux
téléspectateurs vous aviez affronté
rouen l'ogre de fédérale 3 qui est monté
d'ailleurs en fédérale 2 est je crois un
qui domine tout à fait en proprement en
tout cas amplement cette poule de
fédérale 2 un match intéressante que
j'ai noté un récemment celui de la
reprise le 5 janvier dernier sur la
pelouse de l'union des bords de marne
victoire très importante je pense un
10-3 c'est peut-être le genre de match
que vous auriez peut-être perdu l'année
dernière non tout à fait c'est une bonne
remarque parce que le l'an dernier des
matches accrochés comme ça des périodes
un petit peu difficile en plein hiver on
avait peut-être pas
l'expérience là la confiance en soi pour
pouvoir revenir d'un déplacement avec la
victoire cette année bon on l'a fait
sans gros problème même si le score est
pas énorme il n'y avait pas photo sur ce
match là non plus donc je pense qu'on a
on a acquis cette expérience qui nous
permet donc de voir venir et je pense
que les équipes qui nous battrons sont
des équipes qui sont vraiment d'un
niveau supérieur je pense que cette
année on ne perdra plus contre les
petites équipes et puis il ya toujours
des matchs un petit peu piège on a
souvent ce terme à la bouche parce que
c'est la reprise il fait froid les
terrains sont souvent très dures il peut
pleuvoir donc le ballon glissant ça ça
empêche un peu va votre jeu 1 vers
l'avant et votre jeu léché oui oui les
terrains lourds en plein hiver c'est pas
notre spécialité maintenant quand on
vise une deuxième place au championnat
on doit être capable de jouer toute la
saison quel que soit le terrain pour
l'instant ça ça nous réussit pas on a eu
la chance avec cette année ne pas avoir
d des tempêtes le week-end je sais même
pas si on a joué une fois sous la pluie
donc trois dossiers
depuis hier dans les tribunes et alors
par rapport à cette deuxième place c'est
vraiment l'objectif affiché on peut pas
les cheveux chercher orléans sur la fin
de saison c'est trop compliqué c'est un
peu compliqué maintenant même si bon à
orléans ont fait un super match
puisqu'on perdre deux points d'une
pénalité à la dernière minute on menait
quand même à rouler en trois essais à 1
donc c'est pas une équipe qui est très
au dessus de nous malheureusement on a
eu cet échec en début de saison à
vincennes
match qui était mal embarquée qui va
nous rester sur bas sur le dos et au
niveau comptable il manque ces points là
sinon en l'ayant valero jouer chez nous
à la maison et avec l'objectif quand
même comme l'an dernier de les battre
chez nous même s'ils sont premiers de
poule doyen vincennes un jeu pour le
rappeler c'est la seule des deux équipes
qui vous a battu sur la phase aller en
plus une équipe qui est un peu dans la
seconde moitié de tableau et c'est vrai
que ça fait un bain un peu tache sur ce
bilan d' pour l'instant de saison en
tout cas oui surtout de la façon dont
s'était passé on était tombé dans le
piège ont mené largement il tomber dans
la la bagarre de rue ou et ça nous avait
pas réussi on a vu des joueurs pénalisé
puis une défaite au bout d'un point qui
finalement ben voilà nous nous manque
maintenant quoi les points de vente
maintenant pour viser la première place
mais bon une deuxième place serait déjà
un bel exploit pour le club de plaisir
qui est quand même pas un des ténors
annoncés de la troisième division mais
qui tient bien sa place cette saison
vous parliez on en parlait tout à
l'heure de pontault combault c'est le
prochain grand rendez vous le 16 février
match justement un déplacement chez le
troisième ça va être le match décisif
pour ce sprint final je pense que la
deuxième place se jouera ce jour là
puisque mon même s'ils sont à 8 points
de nous ils ont un match en retard qui
peuvent gagner et s'ils nous battent ce
jour là ça vous reviendra à égalité la
fin de saison après ça sera une bataille
de bonus offensif chez les petits donc
il faut faire un résultat là bas l'an
dernier n'avait perdu 2,3 points on les
a battus chez nous largement match aller
l'équipe en confiance doit pouvoir
essayer d'aller faire un résultat là bas
je suis assez optimiste c'est peut-être
la saison la plus complète un que vous
accomplissez c'est peut-être la saison
idéale pour vous aussi en fin de saison
pour c'est pour ces playoffs non oui
pour l'instant on a donc les résultats
de cette deuxième place qui est quand
même bien bien établie donc des phases
finales qui vont être joués ça c'est sûr
maintenant
donc on peut commencer à travailler pour
justement le mois d'avril cette phase
finale
et puis à penser à ce qui se passerait
l'année prochaine si éventuellement il y
avait une montée au bout parce qu'elle
bon
même si
je pense pas que actuellement le club et
les le dos suffisamment solide pour
jouer en fédérale 2 si jamais c'est
gagner sur le terrain il y aura
peut-être discussion très bien on suivra
ça de près prochain match dimanche au
stade robert barran comme d'habitude à
plaisir face à boulogne billancourt
merci beaucoup philippe d'être passés
sur les 7,8 martial très bientôt une
soirée ne leur parlez pas de véhicule
hybride dernière génération pour ces
passionnés d'automobile des voitures
anciennes sont les reines éternel de la
route une cinquantaine d'équipages
étaient réunis à la troisième édition du
rallye de la nocturne à versailles ce
week-end jonathan lynn mal pour les
images
jean marc et nicolas ont dévalé les
routes yvelinoise à bord d'une jaguar de
1955 pour ces passionnés ce bijou de
mécanique n'a absolument pas sa place
dans un musée est bel et bien sur le
macadam on continue à les faire vivre ce
qui est beaucoup plus important parce
que vous avez derrière nous une voiture
qui n'a jamais été restauré c'est une
voiture qui a couru dans une partie de
sa vie et qui continue à courir elle
sera au mans classic elle a été au mans
classic dans les années passées setc des
voitures qui continue
évidemment s'improvise pas spécialiste
de silca de coccinelles et autres 4l
cette passion se transmet de génération
en génération
ça vient de mon grand père qui avait
bonne collection qui a transmis la
passion à mon père et ses sets à zéro 6
voilà depuis que j'ai 15 16
récollets tous les week-ends sur ce
rallye d'une centaine de kilomètres
répartis en deux étapes le chronomètre
n'avait pas d'importance seule comptait
la qualité de la navigation des
équipages c'est l'esprit club sait
pouvoir se déplacer ensemble à des
vitesses à peu près comparable ce qui
fait que les gens les gens arrivent à
suivre et puis si la découverte d'hier
soir on a eu une épreuve de nuit on a
roulé jusqu'à
et la fosse orienté de nuit c'est assez
compliqué la lampe de poche dans les
dents pour lire le road book mais mais
ça fait partie du jeu c'est très sympa
toujours aussi sympa les jeunes y avait
de la neige les conditions étaient moins
bonnes non moi c'était s'était dégagée
c'était sympa très très bien à refaire
l'arrivée souvent le pire des moments
car la chevauchée s'arrête il faut alors
rangé ses vieilles dames au garage
jusqu'à leur prochaine par a
allez on passe à notre entretien
baseball
depuis pas mal d'années il fait la
fierté des cougars formé à montigny
frédéric envie partant telle aventure
professionnelle au japon après un
contrat précédent aux états unis il ya
quelques années il est avec nous sur le
7-8 sport bonsoir frédéric bisson alors
première question j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya quand même eu beaucoup de
chemin parcouru entre ses toutes
premières frappes à montigny à l'âge de
10 ans et puis bah votre prochain départ
dans les prochaines heures les prochains
jours du côté du japon oui c'est sûr
j'ai commencé le baseball hammouti quand
j'avais 10 ans et maintenant je parle
japon la semaine prochaine et entre les
deux je suis passé par le pôle france de
dos rond par lindsay par le pôle france
de toulouse les états unis et
l'australie le canada je l'avais fait le
tour du monde en fin de contrat presque
est avant de revenir un peu en un peu
plus amplement sur votre parcours je
vous propose de revenir un peu sur les
souvenirs à montigny même on a retrouvé
on a fait notre enquête on a retrouvé
quelques photos de vous tout jeune on va
aller voir qui s'affiche à l'écran vous
étiez vous aviez à peu près de 12 13 ans
voilà on va on vous voit ça s'affiche
vous êtes dans le cercle rouge à chaque
fois sur chaque photo avec
notamment jeff l'entraîneur mythique des
des cougars jean-françois duchaussoy
s'est elle est belle époque des belles
années à montigny ah oui c'est sûr c'est
qu'à cette époque là que j'ai commencé à
vraiment aimer aimer le baseball on a
fait on a eu pas mal de titres de
champion de france
s'était joué - bande de copains donc
c'est pour moi c'était super c'est ce
que m'a confié d'ailleurs jean-françois
duchaussoy me disait c'était la bande de
copains du centre commercial un petit
peu il est isolé un petit peu partout
mais c'était tout le temps ensemble en
tout cas sur le terrain d'ailleurs par
rapport à votre capacité mentale et
surtout de joueurs sur le terrain bas je
lui ai posé la question je suis allé le
rencontrer et voilà ce qu'il m'a dit on
l'écouté on état d'esprit idéal toujours
le sourire plus que nous des fois même
mais toujours le sourire qui rate une
balle qui rate un exercice par une en or
ayant raté pas beaucoup mais toujours a
toujours le sourire aux lèvres donc un
plaisir à plaisir à diriger un plaisir à
coacher par contre au niveau de la
course à pied est fred c'était je me
tranquillement le petit pas d'accord
c'est lé pa antillais mais pas loin
qu'un foued c'est pas ses origines mais
c'était parce qu'il fallut limande
épouse de la course à pied bon par
contre au niveau de la vision du jeu et
de la frappe attention monsieur assurer
nos tout de suite à la course à pied
c'est réglé maintenant ça a changé
d'ailleurs je crois que vous jouez en
plus en tant que champ extérieur donc il
faut quand même maintenant ça ne savent
rien un petit peu un salut profond mais
très bien ce sont comme quoi on peut
évoluer au sein au sein d'une carrière
tout le potentiel peut vite progressé
par rapport à votre expérience futur au
japon dont vous partez ce jeudi donc là
j'imagine que vous êtes dans les valises
pour évoluer cette saison avec les
fighting ducks de kochi c'est un nouveau
challenge une façon de repartir de plus
belle pour vous oui j'ai cette année je
joue en france donc je vais j'ai décidé
de changer de cap et de revenir en tant
que professionnel donc j'ai décidé de
porter au japon parce que pour moi c'est
pg du baseball ils ont été champions du
monde plusieurs fois d'affilée je me
suis dit pour moi c'est
le meilleur chemin pour vous alors vous
allez avoir 25 ans cette année vous êtes
le deuxième joueur de l'histoire du
baseball français à avoir signé un
contrat professionnel avec une
organisation de madjar ligue aux états
unis de baseball ça c'est quelque chose
qui marque une carrière d'un sportif de
haut niveau oui c'est sûr c'était c'est
le rêve d'enfant donc quand j'ai
commencé le baseball pour moi c'était
l'objectif c'était s'est dessinée dans
une entreprise la nation américaine et
j'ai réussi à le faire donc c'était un
bonheur tout seul comment s'est passée
cette expérience justement aux etats
unis c'est pas ça et ça c'est un peu mal
fini je sais il ya eu ce contrat résigné
mais vous en avez tiré des enseignements
pour la suite de votre carrière oui tout
à fait je suis arrivé là bas en tant que
français donc personne savait que les
français jouent au baseball j'ai eu pas
mal de bonnes expériences les coaches
ont bien aimé mon prix pas le show j'ai
pu rencontrer leur des bonnes personnes
de bons joueurs et qui change quand le
contacte donc pour moi c'était vraiment
une super expérience revenir en france
un vouliez vous avez rejouer quelques
temps avec notamment le scénar le club
de sénart ces dernières années c'est pas
trop difficile d'évoluer à haut niveau
dans un pays où le baseball n'est pas
considéré à sa juste valeur
c'est plus outre-atlantique un cas c'est
le sport roi
pas vraiment non ça donne justement plus
envié de performer avec l'équipe de
france afin de faire reconnaître le
baseball en france donc on s'entraîne
toujours tous les jours on essaie de
gagner plus de matchs possibles au
niveau européen
à 25 ans vous êtes l'un des cadres on va
dire de cette équipe de france vous en
parler c'est exceptionnel déjà 7 à jade
d'être aussi important dans une
sélection non bien sûr j'ai eu la chance
de jouer à l'étranger 4 4 ou 5 ans donc
c'est normal que je sois un des cadres
la plupart des joueurs français n'ont
évolué qu'en france donc pour les
coaches normal que je sois vous le
rapportez justement dans l'expérience
vous voyez d'autres façons de jouer
d'autre façon de s'entraîner c'est
peut-être ça qui qui peut faire
progresser vos partenaires au niveau du
leadership sur le terrain j'ai plus
l'habitude on va dire de savoir quand
est-ce qu'il faut pousser pour remporter
des matchs vous parliez tout à l'heure
de votre choix du japon ce qui a
peut-être fait votre décision c'est la
popularité justement de ce sport là bas
parce que c'est l'équivalent du football
ici un petit peu dans à tout à fait mais
c'est le sport numéro 1 au japon donc
c'est vraiment c'est que tout le monde
regarde la télé dont tout le monde parle
dans les journaux à la télévision donc
c'est une autre un autre monde sait ça
je sais que vous revenez régulièrement
l'intimé c'est c'est vital pour vous de
revenir un petit peu aux sources de
revoir un peu bas les cougars tout ça
c'est important je montrais mettre trois
fois par semaine avec eux donc ça me
permet de revoir les anciens joueurs à
qui j'ai évolué de voir les coachs de
discuter avec eux de leur apporter mon
expérience et mon aise pour les
entraînements très bien bas vous partez
je crois donc jeudi pour le japon bonne
chance et bonne route on espère vous
revoir bientôt sur le plateau 17,8 sport
avec de beaux trophées peut-être revenu
de là-bas et merci beaucoup d'être
passés sur les 7,8 sport à très bientôt
nathalie renard et instructeur de krav
maga et guyancourt et surtout elle est
la première femme diplômée de france de
sa fédération portrait d'une sportif
passionné qui inculque des techniques de
défense accessible à tous reportage
réalisé avec elodie moines
aller à la plage nous il y a cinq ans
nathalie renard souhaite retrouver une
activité sportive et découvre le krav
maga ancienne gymnaste de haut niveau
ses qualités physiques lui ont vite
permis de s'adapter aux techniques de
combat au bout seulement de trois
saisons l'élève passe le diplôme
d'instructeur je trouvais qu'il y avait
pas cette femme au cours voilà et
il y en avait quelques unes et c'est
vrai que quand on en discutant à
l'extérieur de de cette activité
sportive
beaucoup de femmes agissait en
j'aimerais bien essayé mais ça me fait
un peu plus renoncer trop violent
nathalie la première femme française
diplômée de sa fédération et elle a fait
des émules puisque deux offres
instructrice ont suivi en l'espace de
cinq ans elle a vu les attentes autour
du krav maga évolué quand j'ai commencé
le crav les élèves mais pour
effectivement on se défoule et une
activité
je dirais qu'en mode presque est de plus
en plus
aujourd'hui nous poser la question mais
on peut voit là pourquoi vous voulez
faire de krav maga mais en fait des fois
on n'a même pas besoin de poser la
question les gens viennent et nous
explique voilà moi il m'est arrivé ça et
j'aimerais bien savoir un petit peu me
défendre et c'est utilisée à l'origine
par les forces spéciales israéliennes
le but du krav maga n'est pas de faire
des élèves déco bator père mais plutôt
leur inculquer des techniques d'attaqué
défense permettant de se sortir d'une
situation difficile st est souvent un
autre d'agression mieux savoir se
défendre avant de sur la grèce en fait
donc prendre part le coût direct ou à la
fin on prendre avec le coup et avec
l'armée traîner par terre l'agresseur ça
c'est bon ça marche en deux ans les
effectifs du club de krav maga de
guyancourt au doublé passant de 50 à 105
adhérents 2014
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end
place tout d'abord au football une fois
n'est pas coutume et un week-end un
petit peu contrastée pour les clubs
heavy noir en division d'honneur 18e
journée versailles recevait issy les
moulineaux au stade mont boron mais les
joueurs de david giguet se sont inclinés
2-1 et reste 11e de leur poule toujours
en foot promotion d'honneur 14e journée
trappe s'est imposé à domicile face à
courbevoie 2 1 et remonte à la sixième
place dans la poule c lui en cours se
déplacer à sainte geneviève des bois
mais les joueurs de jute allemand euro
se sont inclinés 3 buts à 2 vous le
voyez à l'écran au classement malgré
cette défaite il remonte d'une place
grâce au goal avérage en fait les
gluants courtois sont désormais
neuvièmes avec 22 points mais avec
seulement deux petites longueurs
d'avancé sur le premier relégable le gia
maccabi paris surtout un match de plus
que ce dernier club en volleyball 8e
journée de régionale une montigny a
signé la performance du week-end lésigny
montain recevait le leader plaisir
villepreux et ils se sont imposés 3 sets
à 2 et au bout du suspense dans un
tie-break décisif 15 points à l'oeuf les
joueurs d'abdellatif nishi reste
néanmoins cinquième de leur poule et
vous le voyez sur l'écran de son côté
sartrouville s'est facilement défait
d'asnières 3 sets à 1 il y avait de
l'escrim ce week-end comme chaque année
le club des scream de trap organisé son
traditionnel challenge jeunes au gymnase
broustal près de 170 escrimeurs étaient
présents sur les pistes issues de 22
clubs du département cette compétition
souvent la première il faut le dire pour
ces futurs champions est aussi
l'occasion pour les maîtres d'armes de
trouver d âme de compétiteur et parmi
les escrimeurs trappistes la jeune anna
bell pratique cette discipline depuis
l'âge de 4 ans et a remporté la
compétition dans la catégorie poussine
sur une touche décisive d'ailleurs je
vous propose de l'écouter ainsi que son
maître d'armes après sa victoire au
micro de jonathan willeman c'était très
difficile jusqu'à que may 5 sur 5
c'est vraiment super difficile j'ai
vraiment étonné d'avoir gagné
vraiment pas s'il est le résultat on
crache pas dessus non plus et aux non
plus on sait que ça les motive plus
quand ils font des résultats mais sait
on insiste vraiment sur la manière sur
le bas le fait qu'ils essaient de
travailler les petits trucs qu'on leur
demande de travailler à la salle et puis
qu'ils essayent de progresser quoi après
si le résultat est bon tant mieux mais
ce résultat n'est pas bon à cet âge là
ça le ils ont encore le temps de
progresser et d'évoluer c'était très
difficile et bravo à la belle à la belle
handball deuxième journée de la phase
finale du championnat de france des
moins de 18 ans plaisir avec un
déplacement très compliqué un chez le
vice-champion de france en titre
dunkerque et les joueurs d'alexandre pas
y faire ce sont lingibé logiquement
inclinées 33 à 23 il reste dernier de
leur poule en roller hockey 8e journée
de nationale 2 et première des matches
retour et l'encours recevait angers
malgré une bonne première période des
chocs ce qui les a vus menés 3 buts à 1
à la pause les joueurs de benjamin
ferran se sont finalement inclinés 7-3
toujours sans victoire cette saison les
jours des élans courtois en n2 semble de
plus en plus comptés il y avait de la
boxe éducative championnats régionaux ce
week-end de boxe éducative catégorie
cadet malheureusement pour le boxing de
la verrière les résultats n'ont pas été
aussi excellent que chez les minimes qui
avait décroché cinq titres je vous le
rappelle il ya quinze jours puisque
aucun des trois boxeurs engagés ne s'est
qualifiée ce week-end pour les inter
régions dernière étape avant les
championnats de france c'est enfin le
grand jour ce jeudi 30 janvier le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
sera officiellement inauguré cette
soirée où seront attendus près de 6000
personnes dans les tribunes verra
notamment le remake de la finale de
vitesse par équipes des derniers jeux
olympiques entre la france et la grande
bretagne nous reviendrons évidemment
détails sur l'événement dans le 7-8
l'actu avec wilfrid riches y ait dans le
prochain 7,8 sport enfin une info de
basket en ce début d'année 2014 la ligue
francilienne de basket-ball a passé pour
la première fois le cap des 60 me
licencier 1 sûrement à cause des bonnes
performances de l'équipe de france
autour de tony parker en un an les
yvelines ont gagné plus de 2 % de
licenciés avec plus de dix mille sept
cents pratiquants mais surtout parmi les
dix clubs français les plus attractives
du pays se trouve à la deuxième place et
bien tout simplement
tante le chesnay versailles avec 637
licenciés que vous voyez à l'image et
pour finir comme d'habitude cette
édition du 7 8 sports place à votre âge
à 20 du week-end et deux de rendez vous
à ne pas rater tout d'abord de la course
d'orientation avec la nuit du castor la
compétition se déroulera cette année au
vaux de cernay départ à partir de 16h30
pour le coup le circuit long et 18
heures pour le circuit court ici vous
n'avez pas réussi à décrocher un billet
tout précieux le précieux sésame pour la
soirée d'inauguration soyez rassurez
vous pourrez découvrir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout le
week-end lors de deux journées portes
ouvertes voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8
sport merci encore une fois un de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter sur les réseaux sociaux et
twitter avec le hashtag le 7-8 sport
tout attaché d'ici là excellente soirée
sur tv fils à lundi prochain